is there something teachers can do to do
this more effectively so you must you
mentioned the textbook yeah so so what
what are the additional things you can
add on top of this whole
old school traditional way of teaching
that can improve the the process
so i do think there's a way of teaching
maths that changes everything for kids
and teachers so i'm one of five writers
of a new framework for the state of
california new maths framework it's
coming out next year
and we are recommending through this
maths framework that people teach in
this way it's called teaching to
big
ideas so um
at the moment people have standards that
have been written and then textbooks
have taken these standards and made
not very good questions
and if you look at the standards like i
have some written down here just reading
the standards it makes math seem really
boring and uninspiring
what are the kind of can you give a few
examples what so
this is an interesting example in third
grade there are three different
standards about unit squares
okay um so this is one of them a square
with side length one unit called a unit
square is said to have one square unit
of area and can be used to measure area
and that's something you're expected to
learn
that is something that so that's a
standard the textbook authors say oh i'm
going to make a question about that and
they translate the standards into narrow
questions
and then you measure success by your
ability to deliver on on these standards
so the standards themselves uh i think
of maths and many people think maths in
this way is a subject of like a few big
ideas and really important connections
between them
so like you could think of it as like a
network map of ideas and connections
and what standards do is they take that
beautiful map and they chop it up like
this into lots of little pieces and they
deliver the pieces to schools and
so teachers don't see the connections
between ideas in order the kids so
anyway this is a bit of a long way of
saying that what we've done in this new
initiative
is we have set out maths as a set of big
ideas
and connections between them so this is
a
grade three
so instead of there being
60 standards
we've said
well you can
pull these different standards to get in
with each other
and
um
also value the ways these are connected
and by the way for people who are just
listening we're looking at a small
number of like big concepts within
mathematics
square tiles measuring fractions shape
and time
and then how they're interconnected
and so the goal is for this is for grade
three for example yeah
and so we've set out for the state of
california the whole of mathematics k
10 as a set of big ideas and connections
so
we know that teachers it works really
well if they say okay so a big idea in
my grade
is
measuring
um and instead of reading five
procedural statements that involve
measuring
they think okay measuring is a big idea
what rich deep activity can i use that
teaches measuring to kids and as kids
work on these deep rich activities maybe
over a few days
turns out a lot of maths comes into it
so
we're recommending that let's not teach
maths according to all these multiple
multiple statements
and lots and lots of short questions
instead let's teach maths by thinking
about what are the big ideas and what
are really rich deep activities that
teach those big ideas so that's the like
how you teach it and maximize learning
what about like from a school district
perspective
like measuring
how well you're doing you know grades
and tests and stuff like that do you
throw those out or is there is it i'm
not a fan of grades and tests um myself
i think
grades are fine if they're
used at the end of a course
so at the end of my maths course i might
get a grade because a grade is meant to
be a summative measure it kind of
describes your
summative achievement but the problem we
have in maths classrooms across the uh
the us is people use grades all the time
every week or every day even
my own kids when they went through high
school technology has not helped with
this when they went through high school
they knew they had been graded for
everything they did everything
and not only were they being graded for
everything but they could see it in the
grade book online and it would alter
every class they went into so
this is the ultimate what i think of as
a performance culture you're there to
perform somebody's measuring you you see
your score
um
so i think that's not conducive for
deep learning
and yes have a grade at the end of the
year but during the year you can assess
kids in much better ways like teachers
can
a great way of assessing kids is to give
them a rubric
that kind of outlines what they're
learning over the course of a unit or a
few weeks
so kids can actually see the journey
they're on like this is what we're doing
mathematically
sometimes they self-assess on those
units
and then teachers
um will show where what they can what
the kids can do with a rubric and also
write notes like you know in the next
few weeks you might like to learn to do
this so um
so instead of kids just thinking about
i'm an a kid or a b kid or i have this
letter attached to me they're actually
seeing mathematically what's important
and they're involved in the process of
knowing where they are mathematically
at the end of the year sure they can
have a grade but um during the year they
get these much more informative measures
i i do think
this this might be more for college but
maybe not i'd some of the best classes
i've had is when
i got a special
like set aside
like the the professor
clearly saw that i was interested in
some aspect of a thing
and then um i have
a few in mind and one in particular but
he said that um
he kind of challenged me so this is
outside of grades and all that that kind
of stuff
that
basically it's like reverse psychology i
don't i don't think this can be done
and so i gave everything to do that
particular thing so this was happened to
be in an artificial intelligence class
but
i i think that like special treatment of
taking students
who are especially like excellent at a
particular little aspect that you see
their eyes light up
i i often think like maybe it's tempting
for a teacher to think you've already
succeeded there but they're actually
signaling to you that
like you could really launch them on
their way yeah um and i don't know
that's too much to expect from teachers
i think to to to
pay attention to all of that because
it's really difficult but i i just kind
of remember who are the biggest
the most important people in the history
of
my life of education and it's those
people that who really
didn't just like inspire me with their
awesomeness which they did but also just
they pushed me a little yeah like it
gave me a little push
and that requires focusing on the
quote-unquote excellent
uh students in the class yeah i think
what's important though is
teachers to have the perspective that
they don't know who's going to be
excellent at something before they give
out the activity exactly and in our camp
classes that we ran
um
sometimes students would finish ahead of
other students
and we would say to them
can you
write a question that's like this but
different
um
oh and over time we encourage them to
like extend things further
i remember we were doing one activity
where kids were working at the borders
of a square and how big this border
would be in different case sizes
and one of the boys came up uh at the
end of the class and said
i've been thinking about how you do this
with a pentagon
and i said that's fantastic how do you
how what does it look like with pentagon
go you know find out see if you can
discover
so i didn't know he was going to come up
and say that and
i didn't have in my head like this is
the kid who could have this extension
task but
you can still do that as a teacher
when kids get excited about something or
they're doing well in something
have them extend it go further
it's great and then you also like this
is like
teacher and coach
you could say it in different ways to
different students like for me the right
thing to say is uh almost to say
uh i don't think you could do this this
is too hard like that's what i need to
hear it's just like no i you know
there's an immediate push but with some
people if they're a little bit more
i mean it's all has to do with
upbringing how your genetics is
they might be much more that might break
them yeah that might break them so you
have to be also sensitive to that i mean
teaching is really difficult it's really
difficult for this very reason
you